[MUSIC PLAYING]
JENNIFER KOHL: Welcome!
Who's excited to be
here this morning?
[CHEERING]
What started off as
two chapters in 2007
on opposite sides of the
world has gained momentum
as other organizers
like yourselves
have built GDG chapters all over
the world in their local areas.
STACY DEVINO: Honestly, my
favorite thing about GDG global
is meeting people from
all over the world
and really understand what
is different and unique
and what they bring that I
might never encounter otherwise.
VITALY ZASADNYY:
The main goal is
to connect with the
great communities.
That unique chance to
see all these people,
all the elites in one place.
I find this very unique, and
to share our own experience
because we have work to share.
NITYA NARASIMHAN: We have
three goals that we've
been trying to achieve.
One is how do you get actionable
learning for people who
want to transition into tech?
How do you get
representation so you
get under-represented
people showing up?
And basically, now what
makes us do what we do?
Which is like, you
know, we all have
a passion for getting
people, empowering
them to do other things.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
RAYAN AL ZAHAB:
Well, if you want
to have an
[INAUDIBLE] community,
it has to be self-sustainable,
able to actually scale
in the minimum effort possible.
So focus on your community,
but get independent
and self-sustainable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]